hey everyone Avengers infinity war
released its first trailer this week and
we got new looks at Thanos The Avengers
galaxy spider-man pretty much all the
Marvel characters we've come to know and
love over these past 10 years and yes by
the looks of it one or more of them will
not survive this movie too many people
are gonna survive which will reach their
tragic ends and the MCU narrative or you
know more likely be considered
expendable for not being able to carry
her own solo movies it was just a frosty
thing because it was cold well this is
the need to know everyone it's a weekly
deep dive into all the biggest news this
week so in addition to infinity where
we're also gonna talk about some other
big Marvel news and Justice League we're
gonna compare the different visions of
the movie from Zack Snyder and Joss
Whedon work and we're gonna back in
we're also gonna check in with you guys
on star dust you can click our star dust
download link in the description below
so you can upload your reactions to this
to your favorite movies and TV shows tag
us at new rock stars and then get them
featured on this show by the way I'm
every boss joining me at the table are
Sam masher oh there are people on either
side of me who I'm desperate to
introduce okay let's get started our top
story this week is the Avengers infinity
war trailer everyone ooh
it broke the record for the most viewed
trailer within 24 hours
did you guess the numbers the numbers
game already cuz I think you got it
right
well check out our breakdown that is now
in our channel for all the stuff that
you missed I think we found some goodies
in there but we're gonna talk about here
let's actually hear from Ben who is
awesome and he sent us a ton of thoughts
on infinity war on the trailer to us on
Stardust Ben take it away one more thing
about Iron Man when you watch the
trailer you can actually see the credits
where he's at and like a gold background
it actually looks like he's crying now I
believe this is a death because of
someone but and I think it's either like
vision because he's created a vision and
stuff so obviously that would be one or
someone else like Black Widow
I am the prize with the Tia oh I already
know who's dying oh I figured it out
sorry we'll get to that well yeah Ben
that's right vision created through a
fusion of a Tony Stark's Jarvis AI an
Ultron synthetic body and mind so yeah
he definitely seems to be in some huge
danger that brings up one of the most
interesting mysteries of adventurers
infinity or which of these Marvel heroes
will survive which won't nfinity war is
planned to be only the first part of a
two-part event Marvel head Kevin Feige
has said the second of those two
Avengers four will be the end of Marvel
phase 3 hinting for surety changing of
the guard at that point I'm watching
this trailer yeah we can calculate
vision Iron Man spider-man appear to be
the most directly in physical danger but
we had yeah I mean he's gotten he's got
he's got like six movies though yeah
they're they're gonna go connect out
forever yeah right poor Tris away it's
crazy we have been misled by trailers
before right Civil War did make it seem
like war machine was straight-up dead so
we can't go directly off of the trailers
we never know if this footage is
actually gonna make it into the final
movie Isis yeah they had it make it look
like Bucky was the one who just shot him
straight in the chest right like 30,000
feet yeah that's cool so they they have
a ton of money they can shoot and
include things in the trailer that won't
be in the movie but I think for now it'd
be good to go through each of these
characters and for us to consider
whether or not we think they will
survive and
what do you guys think yeah let us start
with the the three old dogs Tony Stark
Steve Rogers and Thor okay Thor's gonna
make it just cuz they finally nailed it
also unless it's like he's a maybe
unless they're like you know when
someone like it's on their last stand
here you guys I knocked out he lost his
whole home and from the trailer I'm like
there's a chance that the ship that they
escaped on the Asgardians spoilers for
Thor but we've talked about that before
his whole people might be dead
yeah his all these people might be just
totally gone so point and he got dumped
poor bastard really there's no hope for
him at all exactly because Tony Stark it
would just mean the most cuz that's the
one that everyone can get behind and
Steve Rogers he's been a he's been alive
for so long like a story point of view
I'm looking at at a contractual point of
view they can't keep affording to UM the
Tony Stark Robert Downey jr. there's no
way like that that's like you want to
wrap milking they have milked Hughes the
budget through just his yeah paycheck
alone and he's done he started off in
2008 may that movie came out which means
probably two years before that that was
pre-production he'd signed on that's
over a decade
the boy is done and he's not a boy then
you've got my mate Chris which Chris is
this one again because there's like King
middle one does he wants to want to be
capped I reckon he's done he seems the
most done out of all those people yeah
all their contracts are including
Scarlett Johansson and I think this is
yeah it might be the time I would see I
think Robert Downey jr. might have the
most incentive just because he is being
thrown millions of dollars on his lap
like he said he was done at Iron Man
three right he said that was gonna be
his final and then they were able to
coax him to come back for age of Ultron
and force of war and I think I would say
and also sorry you point we were talking
I think off-camera maybe was in the last
episode you said there is a there's a
significant like monetary jump just by
it putting Robert Downey jr. in these
movies so I think Marvel is willing to
pay out what
ever it is to get that kind of cash
every one of the bodies have work has he
done I think he two three years ago he
put out a movie yeah was like Robert
Duvall or something like that
yeah the judge that's it no he was the
judge him and that didn't do it is he
the kind of artist actor that's thinking
this is deterring from what I really
want to be doing and I think yes he
needed Iron Man to reap repel his career
and now that it's done that in such a
great way I think he wants to break off
like yeah and I think narrative Lee
speaking cat might have the biggest
target on his bed his shield is colored
and shaped like a target he has I mean
that it's spoiler for some of the comics
but Steve Rogers has been used in the
past as kind of this scapegoat figure
this sacrificial lamb whose death has
been used to convey the impact all these
characters have died in different points
the comics they're not really spoiling
anything especially they they could
stone they could reverse all their
deaths so don't don't think that even
their deaths will be permanent
yes and no one ever really died
sometimes but I would say that when in
the past Steve Rogers Captain America's
death has been using comics it was to
make a political statement that I could
see one of these infinity War part one
apart to trying to echo again what what
does it mean when the Captain America
dies yeah I don't know I think out of
all of them if I were to just vote on
one probably Chris Evans he seems like
he's ready to go
you got Bucky ready to go you could have
Falcon take over you wanted to you have
like a little little there you go as a
crew as I kid like back yet understudies
ready to go take up the role you know
yeah but yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah well let's move on to some more
Avengers here Bruce Banner Hulk and
Natasha Romanov Black Widow what do you
guys think about their chances Bruce or
Mark Ruffalo said in an interview that
he and foggy came up with a three movie
arc from Ragnarok on so you know he's
good
I think he's safe yeah yeah and
but Black Widow I've never seen this her
like totally like in it you know like
she's not like but again she was in a
nine-man like that's she's been doing
this character for the longest just not
the most concentrated you know solo
movie ask kind of right there room for
it is the climate showing that she could
have her own maybe yes I'm not counting
her out and she just got a makeover so
that means it still they've still got so
I'm gonna give and guess what guys put
that thing again what the fingers did
but the finger comes down no becomes a
horror movie then they are more likely
to be done yeah I work in that room I
actually think that they're both
probably safe yeah yeah age of Ultron
sort of loves whatever that was so much
room to grow it was kind of there and
then nothing and then it's like they got
a kiss and make up you know yeah yeah
and you got a little hint of that in the
trailer which was kind of cool right
yeah I pointed to had a breakdown but I
like the way the whole Buster arm was
stretched out it almost felt like she
was ready just to go across the wait
what is it was like the sun's going down
to something yeah yeah yeah let's move
on to another grouping kind of the
arguably be list of the Avengers
including by Scott Lang Rhodey and Sam
Wilson those guys how do we feel about
them he's gonna yeah yeah and Scott's
got a movie coming right right ed just
two months after this one comes out so
he's probably good roadie man like you
really put him through the ringer and
haven't given him any growth at all
don't kill him like just don't don't do
that that's not fair just give him get
make him like the Hitman make him like
how they handled like black panther they
introduced this new character but he was
also like a through-line for civil war
how it was like oh his father's death
actually is propelling him to go on a
mission yeah Rodie like he's now
paralyzed make make that like that could
be a really cool thing of like going up
against the scene like threat maybe
maybe he could take over his Iron Man
there's plenty of stuff there's plenty
if the
eggs to fly oh you put like a little
thing in there you can walk again make a
little robot legs yeah I think there is
a scenario where ant-man could go only
because they've been jumping around in
the timeline I'm kinda I've been lately
piecing together the MCU timeline and it
jumps around even more than I realized
and you know we all know there was our
whole thing with homecoming where it
took place like eight years after the
events of Avengers but also at the same
time Civil War did so there's like a big
time thing there I'm wondering if the
events of ant-man and the wasp will take
place earlier than what we might think I
don't I don't know III there's a chance
that it could be earlier in the timeline
and then that's why we haven't really
seen a man in infinity were oh my
goodness there's a shot in the Civil War
comic where they had Goliath he was like
he was like giant man he they had a
thorn for some reason goes crazy he's
like a robot or something blows a hole
through Goliath's chest and he dies as a
giant imaginative Scott Lang's like I
got Thanos and he does like giant man
goes in they know stops the punch and
yeah they would never get that violent
but like that would be pretty cool I
would send it from the die but like it
would be pretty cool
well you can't spell giant without and
it's been staring us in the face all
this time let's move on to another pair
envisioned in Wanda Maximoff Scarlet
Witch I don't know a lot of their
relationship in this one because he no
longer is sort of vision you see him as
the Paul Bettany and I think that you
know that's like the last hurrah gonna
get they're gonna realize this
relationship could be perfect and then
yeah away from us and that's where we
get tears yes I just think I don't
really see a future for either either of
these characters at least beyond the
second Avengers infinity war movie yeah
like I don't see either them hosting
their own movie franchise I could see
them more valuable in terms of like
narrative gut-punched and killing them
off unfortunately he's far at forehead
right I'm in America for head and with
that gone which we kind of know that
that's happening he's sort of gone and
then sure any purpose is to have a
relationship with him now that her bro
is well you did not see that coming
he didn't I mean he wasn't that great
hate to say that that's her only purpose
but so far that has been really you know
like she's such a rich character that
you could get a lot more out of her in
Civil War you got a little bit more it
was like it was trying to that no one
really knows what to do with her because
she's so powerful if she really lost
control which you could get that in this
if you did kill off vision we had her
just lose her goddamn mind that was the
idea of it was cool it was a nice cool
way he's like Wolverines bodies grouping
a pot to try and say very was I
I do love Kelsey Grammer jumping around
roaring all over the place this week I
miss I wish that was a part of these
movies I'll be honest I wish I was the
part of Frazier but well let's say these
the next three seem like safe bets here
just because it does seem like they are
probably gonna have future films like so
Peter Parker spider-man Stephen strange
Doctor Strange and black panther now
only spider-man seems like he's cuz Tom
Holland let's slip in interviews that
there probably will be two more films
but the success of Doctor Strange and
the probable success of black panther
will probably give them even started
their journey yet I mean way compared to
Iron Man which is going on for over a
decade and these guys are just getting
the wind in their sails we gotta let him
so you know yeah no I think they're all
safe also it's a dope black panther
picture yeah yeah really cool I'm not
sure but that's a really cool picture
not if his nails are out he would be
stabbing himself in the hint many
whatever not ideal I've got to get this
off my chest you guys remember the
Family Guy episode where Meg they all
get superpowers and Meg is just to grow
her nails it's just like a little bit
moving on to our next group the
guardians of the galaxy
beautiful star-lord grood rocket Drax
Gamora nebula and mantis now I think the
only one of that group that I think we
might have to worry about would be
nebula point the relationship with
feyo's and the what nebula plays a very
big role in the infinity war comics so I
I could see her having to play some role
like as I mean it's kind of weird like
she could almost be like the cap thing
where the cap with his honor would
sacrifice himself to save the group but
in a way like she would it's that a
turning point where she realizes this is
something that she has to do not wants
to do I said she would do it and then
you know I really I think Gamora might
die in this movie I think she might have
weirdly cuz I think she's gonna like get
her and nebula and get wrapped up and
trying to kill thanos and that could
lead to her coming back because they're
gonna bring her back and she'll be in
like the third guardians movie to like
wrap it all up I don't think she'd be
permanently dead but there's like this
big plot point with her I just spit and
went over that was cool
but there's a there it is oh cool zoom
in right over there it's right there uh
no there's a big plot point where she
kind of has to interact with the
soulstone it makes her like a more rich
character so there is something you
could do there also if you just want to
take a little bit of a risk kill one of
this team like one person maybe maybe
good more or Drax cuz Drax like whole
drive is to kill thanos yeah
like that's his whole thing to revenge
his family we've got a lot sorry
number two yeah yeah and and him going
crazy in the in the first one like
making the was it
Ronan's forces come that's what it was
so I could see them the people who are
most obsessed with killing Thanos dying
but they definitely come back or is
everyone just gonna die because that's
what happened that's what happens yeah
no no we'll have to wait you throw a
little pebble in this pond
yeah I think it just depends on like how
many oh how much fun does Kevin Feige
and Marvel Studios want to have with
each of these characters and I feel like
the guardians there's still so much
potential for different alternate
stories I think that also applies to our
next group like the the people we met in
Thor Ragnarok and we've seen in the Thor
franchise a Loki Valkyrie
burg heimdal of course and then also
side-characters from dr. chariots like
Wang and upcoming black panther Ocoee a
played by Michonne from what commit she
the actress has a name tonight career
but I think there's a lot of chance
because these are kind of lieutenant
level characters yeah a lot of them
could go but I don't think any of them
will I think there's just a lot of fun
to be had there in the Infinity Gauntlet
story there Mephisto who's like the
devil of Marvel he is like the sidekick
who's kind of like strung along with
Thanos to watch what he does
Loki could be that character where he's
like where he finally reaches the point
of like I can't get away anymore of like
I if I run he'll kill me so maybe I can
kind of like weasel my way in here and
figure out a way to like if it would be
pretty great if he liked the trickster
somehow got it on his own arm like if he
got the Infinity Gauntlet for himself I
feel like he would I mean he's going to
betray the group again because that's
what he did yeah that's what DNA and
fans love that it's not annoying at all
the story yeah he's old but I think
hopefully that's him giving it over so
he they don't stop killing the rest of
the Asgardians the 100 that are left
near that ship
how many are left the last group that I
think are actually very vulnerable Nick
Fury Pepper Potts and happy Hogan who
were the last two definitely in the very
first MC with Iron Man and Nick Fury
like the fact that they led the trailer
with his voice the fact that like he
seems to perform over one Winter Soldier
like I don't see a version of this where
Nick Fury survives really because the
Avengers initiative was his kind of
brainchild and kind of poetic yeah I
definitely like if if Tony Stark's
crying it's either Spider Man happy or
pepper and it's probably like probably
since they already did one whole movie
on happy being in the hospital and being
hurt probably pepper
yeah probably pepper probably bubbly
pepper probably Pepper Potts going to
kick the bucket yeah but that would
leave that would leave him to want to
quit the group because it's not worth it
it's like the spider-man effect with
Wednesday see it's like I can't have uni
me and people can't know about me maybe
finally this has happened because
they're very public couple or you get
like a blood
type thing where he like loses his mind
and he goes after Thanos he's super dies
yeah where did we leave it with pepper
with Iron Man 3 does she still have the
extremists abilities nobody in that
movie they're like are we gonna die was
she taken like some medication for a
second I'm like oh maybe she's gonna be
the one to save them all using these
explosive powers I don't know well let
us know your thoughts down below or hit
us up with a reaction to the infinity
war trailer on Stardust and yeah what
we're speaking service let's actually
check in with Janine on start us who
sent us her reaction just watch the
trailer epic oh my gosh seeing everybody
together that running shot with oh my
gosh Captain America the condom oh my
gosh that was so awesome
seeing Dano she actually looked really
good to see Jack wasn't bad way better
than Steppenwolf and him taking vision
stone and I knew Loki was staring at
that tesseract in Thor Ragnarok so I
knew he was gonna take it everybody
looked good running together so much fun
oh yeah I love her enthusiasm yeah so
cool yeah he's got the perfect hair
you know like cat it's just the perfect
hair it's just a bob you've got Falcon
war machine flying you got a whole
blending in with the background cuz
they're green what is it about running
shots guys like Civil War had that great
running shot that was like lines of
people running that's very x-men Nana
made like I don't know maybe it is just
we all grew up with X banana made series
we just want to see our favorite super
of running together and Baywatch yeah
stain B yeah a very well uh Thank You
Janine yeah I totally agree and reminder
that for the rest of you can download
start us by clicking on our link in the
description below and post your reaction
tag us at new rock stars and yeah we'll
feature your video in future episodes of
the need to know just like we did with
Janine but let us move on to this week's
trivia question okay so it's blue it
looks like there's we're gonna be
testing our Avengers knowledge here
and I have not seen the question I
promise that's fine okay so here we go
in Avengers age of Ultron what character
did Stanley play in his cameo age of
Ultron okay I I don't remember I have an
idea I don't know if this was age of
Ultron or Civil War though like honestly
like sometimes just get them all makes
an age of civil infinity but no so and
we're looking are we looking for in a
name are we looking for the scenario or
oh wait I don't even think I'm right but
at least I'm confident is what I
remember
I can kind of see it if I squint don't
worry I'll keep talking yeah you're so
great at filling in that was it and I
wrote on the wrong side of the car okay
well later in the show we will reveal
the answer to this question in the
meantime you feel free to write your
answer in the comments below
no cheating the closest answer as
decided by our judges will do our sign
off goodbyes at the end of the video and
do it in whatever dumb voice or amazing
new character they're trying out haven't
heard from tank in a while so much to
tip tanks apartment
we know the loser will have to read our
in other news wrap-up headlines and
they'll have to be hilarious on the spot
but more on that later
[Music]
no one will be tampering with those okay
let's move on to another reaction to the
infinity war trailer on Stardust this
time from a Wong take it away
there's so much to unpack with this
trailer I mean so many characters
I'm counting like what 15 but yeah the
human vision that's really awesome to
see you know they have Paul Bettany
actually be himself you know I actually
see his face but how are they gonna fit
all this into like two two and a half
hours yeah good shirt man yeah sure
thanks man and you were very right two
and half hours isn't really a whole lot
of time to do these characters justice
so I'd like to look at Avengers infinity
war and the MCU by the numbers and this
week's number that I'm most interested
in is the number 20 I feel like this has
to be Street a little bit this week
there is a number 20 brought to you by
20 yeah 20 is the number of new films at
Marvel head Kevin Feige is planning for
the future of Marvel Studios still the
car right we've only seen 17 come out be
released he's got another five that
they've kind of announced when and what
that will be
he's okay let's quote him directly he
said in an interview that after 17
release Marvel films another five
scheduled quote we've got another 20
movies on the docket that are completely
different from anything that's come
before intentionally Wow ant-man he's
different to Iron Man because their
names are different yeah yeah maybe
that's the spider-man venom
oh they got all the mutants in Dark
Phoenix forgetting about right yeah I
mean I don't know I'm like I guess my
question is can Marvel sustain the
popularity of the of the comic book
superhero genre for another 20 films
like this is double well over double
what we've seen so far that's like
another 15 to 20 years of what we've
seen I don't know if any Shawn
that we are going to be taking our
children to see these movies and then my
children's children's to see these
movies because they'll be 20 more after
that we all know it's never gonna end
I currently have an adult son who I will
not be taking another generation ready
to pick up the slack and take it to the
next and I mean even Star Wars was an
unlikely outlier exception where we had
like 15 years of a dark period of no
Star Wars other than like EU novels and
comics and then when they came back it
was such a huge event and then there was
even like at least a dark six or seven
years between force awakens but this
they're releasing two to three films a
year of this ie
I mean I'll go watch all of these surely
I mean you need your breakdowns and the
more you watch them the more formulaic
they are yeah coming if not quite
obviously already I was gonna say don't
don't you dare but of course they are I
was like was thinking about this it was
like Logan was just depressing I can't
watch 20 movies of that how you can take
a superhero movie and pivot the genre
yes but at the end of the day it's still
oh let's say freaking world or let's
save someone or let's you know yeah but
also that's what crime movies are
usually it's there's someone who's in
trouble where they go save them just in
superheroes it's like there's a power
they learn how to use the power here's a
friend then a character dies and then
they say the day yeah I it was
interesting there was I forgot to put
this in here but there was a interview
with Willem Dafoe and Hugh Jackman
recently and they're asked about like
yeah and they both kind of agreed that
like they they just don't know how long
the the appeal of this brand can last
and these are the guys who you know
we're there and yeah early 2000s making
these things before it was cool and
popular before big actors wanted to be
in these movies I don't know I I think
I'd i guess my bigger
how many are there twenty more
characters or twenty movies worth of
other characters that people are that
excited for or even if you reboot them
are people gonna be that excited no no
you new team ones but still that's 20
team movies that's all a man alone has
had three of his own movies and being in
another sort of three or so that six
like yeah I reckon you can get another
twenty cool yeah if you bring it sign in
[Applause]
below you got a guess III think I mean
not to leave this one too cynical no I
mean it clearly come Vigo is probably
just trying to reassure investors be
like no bright future just as bright as
what you've seen so far
probably I mean it's a job it's a job to
like sell this narrative in terms of how
successful the business is going to be
to write they were like here's Marvel's
slate and they're like t sees like yeah
so I I don't know I think it would
require some kind of transformation
Logan type transformation of what
superhero movies feel likes to get away
from that formula great we have like the
next two maybe system spider-man be like
a coming-of-age story where he festivals
in love and I'm talking like Perks of
Being a Wallflower or something Oh super
in being super indeed yeah it's like
homecoming was gonna be that a little
bit no vulture and I was still superhero
movie but I really got to love that
movie um but if we do the whole Fox
moving forward with the bottom disney
buying fox then you could fantastic or
maybe everything
or x-men you can have an x-men a few
timelines for that one yeah yeah times
done now if that I like it but it's like
well because this is a need-to-know we
cover all the news you need to know
about this week so I think we're gonna
shift gears now and pivot from the MCU
to the DC EU okay everybody Justice
League has become one of the most
debated movies of 2017 with many fans
asking for an ultimate cut of Zack
Snyder's original version of the film
now just to be clear this X nighter had
to step down from the movie in the
middle of production he didn't finish a
version of the movie need to step down
unfortunately for tragic family reasons
Warner Brothers hired Joss Whedon to
finish the movie of course just went
from the Avengers and now all the Buffy
yeah he's great
now many viewers believed this caused
some tonal inconsistencies to use a
delegate word a mix of Snyder's darker
more bleak take on the characters and
Whedon's more light-hearted humor driven
style now according to some leaks and
some rumors and people sharing what
they've seen in earlier screens and in
drafts the scripts and a concept art we
have a pretty good idea of exactly which
scenes and lines were changed during
Joss Whedon's reshoots so we're gonna do
a comparison here I thought we could run
down a list of seven major changes and
discuss them what were the weather we
thought they were warranted or whether
they thought made the movie better or
different and what how we feel about
that dig in we have some interesting
stuff here and um we yeah again I just
want to remind you guys the movie we saw
was still mostly Zack Snyder's vision
it's not like Joss Whedon completely
redid the movie I think a lot of those
rumors were blown the story and the
scenes remain pretty much the same but
in many cases yes a dialogue within
those scenes was revised by we didn't
yeah also guys he's he jumped in when
the movie was almost done he did reshoot
a bunch but imagine the amount of work
that would have to go in for him to
rewrite an entire story and get the
whole cast on boy I just wonder how much
is the red pen on the script and how
much is you know what you know the same
improv yeah yeah and I might take
something that isn't the script in front
of me right right and Whedon has been
known to use that stuff just kind of
and ad-libbed a version of this so yeah
even though this thought experiment kind
of creates two different versions of the
movie in our minds at the end of the day
yet there was one movie there was one
Justice League that both directors
collaborated on we should see it as one
final piece but that's it just for the
sake of a thought experiment let's look
at like the two different versions of
this look at the changes and we should
start out here with how the movie begins
okay and zack snyder's cut the movie
opened with the at world without hope
montage set to the Leonard Cohen song
the cover ice agreed and that led
directly into Batman finding and
recruiting Aquaman but in wheat it was
Whedon's decision to add the Superman
cellphone footage well if it wasn't his
decision it was when he was reshooting
it might have been a studio suggestion
he added the Superman cell phone footage
prologue as well as that Batman rooftop
scene that it led into that was all
before the world without hope montage
that we saw so what do you guys think
were you satisfied with Whedon's new
opening in Justice League or would you
prefer its nighters well there was a
thing that came out saying that vit the
cell phone footage was added at the last
second it was one of the latest
additions that's why he looks looks like
it's rougher but because and also a CG
one of the CG artists came on like one
on reddit was like yeah we didn't see
that like we were really proud of like
the close-ups you got later in the movie
because it's like yes it's really hard
to digitally remove something like that
and then rebuild a face but he's like we
were proud when that came out they were
furious because looks awful you know as
I liked the idea of this scene more than
how it was just that was sort of
striking to me when he talks about that
the kids being excited Superman talking
to kids like that's a really good thing
we've never seen especially with his
version of Superman so I am fine with
that I'm yeah I could have actually left
that one that one particularly because
the kids voice acting it's pretty good
kid actors gonna start with that like
when that's the thing that keeps up the
boat and I think the scene went for a
little bit too long the point they were
trying to make could have could have
been made in a much more concise manner
and so like if that's your opening
you're like
but I did like the moment that um Ben
Affleck had on the top of the roof with
their yeah with the villain like Gotham
was cool yeah yeah brought you into
Batman's land he's world again and I
loved her that was and the man who acted
the thug in that scene is also brilliant
in mind hunter I have not watched it yet
I've seen that I'm gonna go look it up
good fantastic this is what you need to
do you put all your eggs in there things
that are you can you know invest in and
that will pay off yeah kids sing yeah I
totally agree I think my biggest thing
is just aesthetically it feels very anti
cinematic you know like cell phone
camera footage and they shot it you know
in the in the vertical of portrait mode
and I like the kind of joke of it I like
the the tonal change I just I like the
opening shot of a movie to be cinematic
so that like you can compare the opening
and closing shot disappear see how the
movie has changed totally it was a cool
I sorry I just I I liked the idea of the
explanation of this I'm saying good
ideas not maybe poor execution
it looks like an S but he's like it
moves like a river it that hope comes
and goes and it's like I'm the one who
yeah which is a cool idea and also it
makes more sense than just saying hey
this is it it's like this hope it's an S
but shut up okay that's not it means
hope all right I think out of everyone
at this table I should be able to relate
to that the most because my tattoo here
exactly doughnut mouth is really
confused it was distracting it was like
the lips don't move right they just like
just let's move it to our next big
change how the flash was used in the
movie
so Snyder conceived the general visuals
in the set pieces for the flash his
meeting with Bruce the Batarang throw
the slow-motion assist with Diana's
sword which I really love yeah but
really Whedon was the one who fleshed
out the soul the character he's the one
who added that save one person
line from Batman setting up Barry's the
hero that was million casualties taking
care of the bystanders any and that
included all the saves in the final
battle that whole Russian family was not
part of the movie until we didn't got on
board so depending on how he felt about
the Russian family there just there is a
symbol of the moment where he actually
weren't realized that oh cool Barry
Allen doesn't really have much of a role
here yeah and if you're in the audience
going well what's he supposed to do the
fact that Batman comes in almost like a
father figure that he doesn't really
have since his father's in prison and
gives him a role it helps you identify
like him to the audience right you're
like oh my god that's right he's just a
speech so he's not really someone who's
a good fighter he just saves people yeah
so like you're able to I don't know
understand Barry so much more and like
the struggle ve had previously I don't
know if that made any sense but know
that bit but know it makes a family was
pointless it was cute when the little
girl got the little the road spit and
we're totally totally pointless it was
like why is this why is this one family
living in this weird reactor but then
like like 90 other people ran out but
still it did lead to one of my favorite
parts of Superman carrying the building
and then flash pushing the car and it's
like it was fun and then he did a dumb
joke of a random Russian author sorry oh
that's random well I it's well for
people don't know that yeah who don't
care to look which I would feel like 90%
of people but also afterwards people are
like oh he was trying to say dosvedanya
which means goodbye in Russia and I'm
like oh I totally read too much into
that probably always that what he's I
think he's trying to say dosvedanya
waving goodbye and he says Dostoevsky
which is a Russian author and
philosopher yeah talks about like people
with like was it like it something about
with people who have powers should have
the responses right it's see an uber
Minch philosophy Oberman meaning
Superman so there's a kind of a fun
connection if we're crazy and we because
I know normal person sorry doesn't know
that yeah it's what I mean it wasn't
just this part we were talk about some
of the jokes we didn't even though flash
was always intended to be a comic relief
character we didn't really lean did that
even more the whole line of him saying
people are slow and Bruce responding
I'll try to keep up and then that bit
with
flash face-planting after tapping diana
sword and referencing Pet Sematary also
the gag with Aquaman Singh on Diana's
last of the truth those were all Whedon
isms which they did feel a bit like
Buffy style jokes but again like I think
when we were talking about Justice
League Aquaman's like the biggest moment
was the last moment of truth like that
was my dialogue and you kind of got an
understanding of who he was as a person
slash hero and yeah all of these best
bits of the flash that are Flash's
Whedon knows how to humanize yeah these
characters by having like a personality
really doesn't know how to inject
personality into the hero no he can look
it just doesn't seem like a priority I
mean I think he can he just has these
other things on his checklist that he
wants to get to first I mean but like
with Watchmen exactly like I mean but
with Watchmen like I never like eat that
movie I have no idea what's happening
even though I've read Watchmen I don't
know what's happening when I watch that
movie
does it look exactly at the comic yes
that doesn't mean anything after the
two-hour mark and I'm like yeah I could
have just read this and it would have
meant more to me yeah so yeah the the
humor was more heavily inspired by
Whedon also the post-credits scenes the
Superman race one with flash that was a
weed and post-credits Lee meanwhile the
Lex Deathstroke one was from Snyder's
version actually there was an earlier
version I don't know if the Snyder
decided to take it out of Deathstroke
actually breaking Lex out of Arkham but
those that of course left on the cutting
room floor let's move on to the third
big one the next big change involves
Steppenwolf and how the mother boxes
were portrayed in the movies so it seems
like there was a super early cut of the
movie maybe even before Zack Snyder's
latest footage that had a longer scene
after Steppenwolf steals some of the box
from the amazonian some famous Kira he
speaks to the device because apparently
the idea was that it contained the
essence of his mother Hagar ax now Hagar
has a sister in the comics and when this
literal mother box would get United with
the other two it would unleash her gross
power actually the words that we heard
Steppenwolf from the script in this part
we heard in the trailer that came out
Comic Con last summer where he goes
there's no protectors here no lanterns
no Kryptonians this world will fall like
the others and there was an added
sentence of you will be free mother
[Music]
and it would have meant more than just
glowy box yeah someone's mother and that
gives him more Drive because it's his
relationship with his mother right if
she's more powerful those together
mother and sons you are like yeah and
speaking to the box instead of just
being like this for Darkseid in the
unity with you it's what is the unit
undefined it might be in the deleted
scenes we'll see when the DVD comes out
also Zack Snyder did shoot for sure a
sequence that showed one of the
Amazonian warriors start to get
transformed into a pair of demon kills
herself before that happens so that
probably will be in the deleted scenes
it sounds like the transition of all of
those who died on the battlefield
becoming the army yeah like knowing we
just saw that one test example and let's
talk about this ancient battle sequence
Steppenwolf's first invasion of earth
this whole part was from Zack Snyder's
vision but there was apparently an even
earlier version that contained actual
dialogue from the characters we saw in
the sequence including Green Lantern
along with Ares Zeus politan and type II
they got those cameos from Robin Wright
and David Thewlis but they were gonna
have lines originally I doubt it does
sound like Joss Whedon's reshoots
reconfigured how much of the Green
Lantern would be in the scene I think it
sounds like he expanded the Cameo to
include Green Lantern's death in the in
the power ring zipping away is it that
was a nice touch yeah I don't think they
need to like plan out like will you okay
this box and then for some reason the
aliens not like you know what leave mall
on earth
I won't take these boxes anywhere else
in the universe we'll just leave them on
earth there's some reason there's a big
plot hole yeah don't why'd you hide it
in one place like he found him in two
seconds hide out of space space is
endless I was happy with how this scene
ended in the movie just because all he
was Dianna's voiceover to really kind of
walk me through it it didn't necessarily
give me more explanation for what's
definitely was all about but I thought
it looked cool and it gave some more
historical weight to what was happening
[Music]
great yeah also they're supposed to talk
they're not like they don't like they
like just like they like they can
communicate with whoever was holding
them so they're they're cool yeah well
next up cyborg was one of the more
Frankensteined literally it seems like
characters throughout the development
process of this movie very early cuts
the movie included some scenes before
his injury which is why we saw those
shots of him playing football and
wearing a letterman jacket the trailers
I didn't up in the final cut the movie
there was a scene between Victor and his
mother including possibly her dad that
he might have actually caused through
one of his like angry moments yeah
Snyder's version the movie included more
scenes with Silas stone his father
including more of that rescue from the
tunnels Whedon trimmed a lot of that
down Whedon's did his research did rely
heavily on cyborg and the third act who
kind of explained on the exposition
because it sounds like in the earlier
versions it wasn't totally clear what
the league's final mission was that said
using him just as an exposition device
didn't totally win me over either I
didn't like he was one my favorite
characters from it I really liked how
they used him yet I'm gonna pitch
something so they saved the father
father's like let me help you somehow
that he goes to the Russian site puts
him in a house to keep him safe oh they
need to save him which father yeah I
would have meant to protect and I think
that was the idea of the tunnels scene
like they were gonna get him out of
there but it sounds like STAR Labs is
gonna be collapsing and you did see
other shots in the trailer where debris
was falling and then cyborg blasted it
out of the way to protect our lab
scientists I think there was a lot more
there involving Silas that he was gonna
be one of these you know saving damsels
that shows other people's heroism we
just didn't end up seeing as much I
didn't need him to kill his own mom I
didn't need I wouldn't have needed that
that's a would also have been worth it
yeah and Barry lost his mom I guess like
there's enough people losing their
mothers we don't right yeah and I didn't
need like him literally killing his mom
like that would be and it was super
ambiguous in the movie of what happened
no one really know they're like
explosion or an accident I don't really
know what happened here but now you have
robot parts so he's mainly robot he's
just got a face yeah mostly machine yeah
okay well let's move on to the next big
change there's a lot involved here
Superman's return right it was a big
centerpiece of the movie a decision to
resurrect him was part of Zack Snyder's
story just played out a little bit
differently in what we've seen during
the countdown as flash used his Speed
Force to jumpstart the mother box at one
cyborg was suddenly going to be struck
with a premonition similar to Bruce's
night mare vision Batman or Superman he
was going to envision the death of the
Justice League the ruins of earth
Darkseid and yeah this is of course cut
from the movie Whedon's reshoots focused
on the close-ups and dialogue for a lot
of the sequence which Snyder might not
even gotten to yet
so it's not like he revised anything he
just like filled it in with his own
voice specifically all of Superman's
lines in the resurrection battle thing
in Metropolis including the whole that
callback do you bleed that was from
Whedon yeah you want to kind of have
purpose and make sense right it's a nice
kind of additionally during the sequence
Whedon added what I thought was one of
the most thematically significant
exchanges of the movie when Bruce admits
to Alfred that they need Superman
because Clark is more human than he
Bruce is to me yeah I was really
unappreciated a lot of the critics
reactions this to me showed yeah there
were evolution of booth in Bruce Bruce
in this film yeah he started as a guy
who sees as well this like kind of a
punch line like I'm rich you know and
then it becomes a guy I realized that
his wealth has created this like lonely
detached person needs a little less
human I love that you making humans and
K like human humanizing these characters
but also you've got to tap into them
feels yeah it's like black explosion
whatever you need to know yeah that
there's something bad symbols for Batman
being the punching bag for a lot of
jokes and also being like I end up but
for reals like I feel like I'm not
really a person anymore
yeah just like Daniel that is a real
character development yeah and then
Snyder's previous version contained a
scene where sue
man actually retrieves his suit from the
Kryptonian ship and that might have been
removed to make his appearance in the
final battle like I believe in truth and
just like maybe that more of a surprise
so because I've seen him we would have
known who's coming yeah because his
suits supposed to have a giant hole in
it right also you should still have a
giant hole in them I mean I guess the
mother box just kind of mechanical which
part the pole should a piece backup like
cyborg like cyborg see so maybe there
was just some logical things that now
the final alteration of all the film's
ending and Darkseid okay so the finale
was totally a fusion of both directors
inputs as the whole movie really was
Snyder conceived most of the general
action but Whedon shot Superman joining
the battle and the interactions between
cyborg and flash and Snyder included
shots of people around the world
watching Steppenwolf's red sky
unification that's kind of from the the
crisis events in the comics they were
removed from the movie maybe they wanted
to avoid that cliche thing of everyone
kind of looking up the Times Square you
know there's anything right yeah it
would have meant more because like right
now okay it's definite amaizing actually
reworked a bunch of times during
production
apparently Snyder had concept art of
Superman Batman and Wonder Woman the
Trinity looking up through the boom tube
and seeing dark side glaring at them on
the other side dark side of that boom
tube and then rumor has it that there
was an even earlier version of the
ending that featured Darkseid actually
killing off Steppenwolf an anger back on
the planet apocalypse promising to
travel earth to meet that Kryptonian was
a really really strong good villain
you actually feared and then that was
like eliminated straight away like
effortlessly then you're like oh there's
always a bigger fish in the pond fish in
the pond yeah this is a pipe yeah
a Whedon's final cut of course featured
the more open-ended child step and being
swallowed up by the parademons back
pulled back through the boom tube and
then it led to that closing montage with
Lois narration and flashes goofy running
Ike it was
Sneijder yeah the running was tonight oh
yeah because I tried it was like it
doesn't feel good it was at first I was
like Oh cuz he's moving so fast he kinda
wants to get like that a little extra
little bit further but even when doing
and I'm like oh this is so hard
ya know I bet on the in the brainstorm
session they're like well quick so
everyone's like this I was like this and
the TV shows like I know how to make
this you mean it's like not the effects
it's how he moves his dumb lanky body
when he's comparing these different
versions of the film is just a thought
experiment every movie goes through
several iterations with deleted scenes
rejected concepts rewritten dialogue
before the final cut that we end up
seeing ultimately that is a version that
should be judged the version that you
saw in theaters actually want to throw
it over to chrono terian on Stardust who
had some positive thoughts on the
version of Stardust that we did see in
theaters
take it away chrono what do you get when
you cross a superhero movie with a
masterpiece
well it's something close to Justice
League the characters were funny and
they were smart and they were true to
the comics the dialog was also funny and
smart
the CGI was I mean Superman's lip but
aside from that it was just a great
movie and I highly recommend it even
though Ron tomatos hates it for some
reason
coronation sounds like I did when I
first came out of seeing The Phantom
Menace
well thanks credit aryan and be sure for
the rest of you to let us know your
thoughts on the changes that we talked
about in the comments below tweet us
directly and if you haven't already
subscribed a new rock stars to see all
of our other videos on Justice League
including our review and the full movie
breakdown that we did on this channel
thanks guys
carnation dude more power to your comic
book fan and if you like this Who am I
to say that it's not good I know choose
a chrono nation and to all the members
of the chrono nation ok let's move on to
our need to know lightning round where
I'm gonna hit you guys with some rapid
fire questions off-the-cuff questions
and answers that you have to answer
these questions you guys were nice
enough to tweet us these earlier I wrote
some of them down make sure to tweet us
next Friday with more questions for our
panel and I'm gonna read them to you
guys rapid-fire here Lee and go Sam and
you could have won infinity stone what
would it be that's for Momo Momo the
time one I wanted to control tiny
Michonne the way to travel
did I get it don't mess with time ok
[Music]
Alexis Sanchez wants to know which of us
do you think would be the best to actor
for an MCU movie act for me someone
asked what other shows does Eric watch
apart from the ones who reviews only
ones a review because I only care about
you guys no I uh I really liked mine
hunter and I'd like Bojack horseman a
lot yeah yeah big fan I can remember
which do seem younger
ok so and a bunch of others that will
give it to my 15 second shadow here we
go Sam
Netflix Marvel shows an order from
favorite to least favorite Jessica Jones
tied Punisher Luke Cage cuz Punisher
actually turned out to be really solid
then daredevil season 2 not season 1
season 2 then defenders daredevil season
1 I'm an iron fist all the way in and
downtown in the dirt okay I get them all
I think I got it
Punisher though it's good Jon Bernthal
yeah he's good mod for Dallas wants to
know the city Dallas wants to know this
is a long one do you think the implied
sex scene with Wonder Woman and Steve
Trevor lessened her independence as she
stated before she read sex books and men
are only good for procreation I would
have preferred that scene if she kind of
had a little bit more determination and
drive behind it and she'd be like page
82 you know we are going to do page 82
tonight that would have been great but
this one I don't know it surprised me
that it was that's not 30 seconds was a
woman's gaze so they didn't feel like a
woman's gaze for that particular moment
but what I did like about it I had a
sensuality instead of like oh right yeah
and they were pretty people know who in
a superhero community would you want one
as a mentor - as a best friend and three
as a love interest wait is that you do
it okay so mentor Tony Stark
Fred's friend I'm haulin not the
character I want to quit you go the
Living Planet cuz I need to get it down
with an entire planet don't read
anything into the casting of the kids
yeah let's all do it oh I'd go with
Wally West or Clark Clark would be great
it can't would be great best friend I
want Tim Drake Robin he'd be a fun one I
like him and then a love interest
Starfire judge me don't judge me
well my mine was Tony Stark because he's
good he's got some Queens ah best friend
Tony Stark again cuz coin quick quick
quick right wing no you seen that but
that's crazy yeah all right let's take a
look at what we got in the pipeline for
videos coming out
the channel next week guys you guys have
been asking the best we got super busy
over the Thanksgiving holiday and was
justly coming out but Sam has a Punisher
full season breakdown to brag it's
coming it's coming it's coming
yes policies whole season baby there's
not that many strikes but there are some
good little catches that you guys will
enjoy and some of you may have seen on
our channel we did initially upload the
Game of Thrones season 1 episode 4 break
and we actually had some technical
issues but that will be coming next week
thank you for your patience we're still
gonna be working on this classic but we
love doing it's one of my favorite
things to do so we will be continuing to
do those I drink and I know things right
okay yeah and as usual we will be doing
episodes of uh episode breakdowns of The
Walking Dead and the flash actually we
got a very special one for crisis on
Earth X the big crossover this year I
did a whole crossover breakdown boys and
girls you better go watch it probably
live on the channel now so just click
over and watch that and then other
videos in the works we do have some more
Star Wars content some more Marvel
content keep your eye out for that some
real exciting stuff coming very cool yes
she will yeah
have you never met him I've asked him a
question once I said who would win in a
fight between the Joker and the Luke
Skywalker and he spoke for about seven
minutes not answering my question
I wish he said he couldn't hear me
because I was crying out of excitement
that would be me
now comes the time for a 15-second
shout-out where each of us is 15 seconds
to shout out plug or ramble about
anything we want Sam why don't you start
50 seconds starting now go Reed Doomsday
Clock it's the it's the spiritual sequel
to Watchmen that they released it is the
most beautiful art I've ever seen the
comic I made it's Geoff Johns and Gary
Frank Gary Frank I will show you guys
after it is beautiful go read it right
now if you've ever read Watchmen before
ok my 15 seconds I finally got around to
watching the Jim and Andy documentary on
Netflix about it's behind the scenes
footage of Jim Carrey on man-in-the-moon
where's the biopic of Andy Kaufman the
avant-garde comedian who influenced
everyone and it really might make you
not like Jim Carrey too much because it
kind of makes him look like an egomaniac
but
yes you never really came out of it I'm
just gonna shout out to a book I'm
reading them the Martian Chronicles by
Ray Bradbury that's great Bradbury I
like you know I've done that one before
but I also shout out to Outlander on
Styles over here do you give you a
moment here we go hi just say I returned
to our trivia questions okay and we have
our answer over here rereading yeah and
you can take this one yeah the in the
Avengers age of Ultron or should be a
question here what character did Stan
Lee play in his cameo sokovia men mm-hmm
city blue oh yeah okay that sounds
actually more like mod says wedding DJ
some sort of event in the beginning of
the movie and it cuts to him and he's
like oh there's a Dead Pool C Murray
played a DJ you're sitting in the front
row at a wedding maybe he's like crying
and clapping yes I don't remember I
don't think anyone got married in that
movie and then I wrote something you
wrote FedEx delivery man but that's the
one from well the answer is Stan Lee
comic book creator he played himself
safe to be the winner there okay so as
the winner mod you will get to do our
good-byes and make fun of our names and
Twitter handles however you like but we
need to find out who our loser who was
the worst that means I definitely was
wrong that's a random sokovia man you
didn't describe the scenes and bashes
[Music]
final word there all right we're gonna
run through our other news headlines
that we didn't plan for and Sam as the
loser of the trivia question you have to
read these at the end of each headline
you have to make a joke to cleverly riff
on the headline it we won't tackle you
will will we that we have your back we
will support you I could take it take it
away thing number one Netflix renewed
stranger things for a third season in
minehunters for a second season I got a
hit right everybody number two oh and
Khal Drogo actor Jason Momoa said after
visiting the set of Game of Thrones
final season the final episode will be
the greatest thing that has ever been a
aired on TV not talking about his I abs
am i right everybody high five good my
hands are wet I'm supportive mark hamill
said in an interview that he wanted Luke
Skywalker to be behind in Star Wars
last Jedi didn't see that coming or
Marvel Robbie said the cheese working on
a separate Harley Quinn saw a movie for
some reason along with Suicide Squad -
and Jared Leto Joker movie Gotham City
sirens and an animated series that makes
live sorry not life that makes five
Harley Quinn projects and development my
own comment on that is a dear god please
I'd rather die and as a joke number 5
rumors are suggesting Warner Brothers
plans to bring to assemble the Legion of
Doom a team DC villains team of DC fans
across the next few DC movies to set up
a future showdown with the Justice
League there are they just gonna be the
executives at Warner Brothers cuz they
basically kill the Justice League movie
that's good
good I haven't been breathing that's
really scary for me I mean a bit of a
warm-up yeah yeah you took about 90
percent of it was a warm-up but you can
really came home there with the last 10
good closing yeah
all right take it away mud I'm gonna
Woodsen be really smug because I feel
like a little bit hey guys I want to
thank the hosts ever on the table Sam
Bass shot Sam I told nine jokes and one
of them was good best shucks you can
find him at Sam Basha Sam betcha never
met her
Eric Voss Voss it's in the name is also
hit that's such a good tag because it
reminds me of the seal is that in your
Twitter bio yet no I'm on it odd you
know it's in there the time
henkle let me in Sweden buy eggs I'm a
button and I'm at Lord Garret
there's only other one of the more
Garrett in the world she's from Nebraska
which is really cool she loves The
Walking Dead and there's every chance
she remember to do well-done poster
reactions on Stardust and Tagus at new
rock stars and so we can see it and we
might feature you in next week's video
guys comment down below and tweet us at
new rock stars using the hashtag need to
know like this video share it around so
scribe into rock stars with deep dives
and all the stuff you love guys see you
next week thank you so much